i want to bring in ben shapiro to talk
more about this ben good morning welcome
back to our program here here's one of
the pieces in the wall street journal
today the message of canada's trucker
protest here's the line the lesson for
the copa 19 police is that when you've
lost even canadians arguably the most
law-abiding people on the planet you've
lost the political plot let's start
there ben
that's absolutely true i mean the fact
is that these oracles at delphi have
decided what we are all supposed to do
for two years now and they lied and they
said it was about the data it was never
about the data it was about control and
about the sense that they could control
things and they can't i mean it's been
amazing to watch as elite institution
after elite institution completely
destroys itself on the basis of the
notion that they are able to control all
of the extraneous events of life and
then reality clocks them in the face and
the people of canada are tired of this
the polls show in september after the
last election cycle that the vast
majority of canadians want justin
trudeau to go whether we're talking
about people from the left to the right
they just don't like trudeau and there's
a reason for that it's because you have
a bunch of authoritarians over there who
have decided that they are going to set
standards that defy science and defy
reason and justin trudeau had ample
warning that this convoy was going to be
coming his way because they've been
planning it for a while they've been
talking about it he could have nipped it
in the bud gone to meet with them done
something but instead ben what do you
think about his basically saying that
they resemble nazis and confederate
soldiers
you know this sort of tactic which
trudeau is picking up from the american
left is likely to be wildly unsuccessful
everybody can look at this convoy and
see that they are not flying nazi flags
on mass that these are not radical right
wingers now this attempt to paint
everybody who is opposed to the
authoritarian tactics of of the
authorities on on covet to nazis and and
far-right crazies it's it's it's going
to backfire it has backfired i mean the
reason that all these places are
changing policy including alberta by the
way which just decided to end a bunch of
its own mandates the reason that they
are doing all of this is because the
people have had enough you're too late
but they've had enough
ben stacey abrams another picture popped
up yesterday afternoon she went on cnn
last night and apologized
there there's more than one picture
all right here's the one that popped up
yesterday her spokesperson said stacy
trusts science
and supports masking in schools as it's
the current cdc recommendation she wore
a mask to the event and removed it at
the podium so she could be heard by
students watching remotely and for
photos but only with folks who were
masked
well i mean i guess that's a step better
than the mayor of l.a who said he did
not breathe for a moment there
yeah i mean this is one of the things
that i think citizens all over the
country and frankly across the world are
just enraged with which is this idea
that the rules don't apply to the
specials and and stacey abrams is one of
these i mean that photo of her sitting
in front of an an entire classroom 50
kids all masked and she's sitting there
grinning wide that's going to be on
every campaign ad run by whoever the
republican nominee is in georgia all the
way until the election day and it should
be because it's ridiculous hypocrisy
it's absurd and everybody knows it it's
interesting that you'd think that she
would have better political instincts
than that because she's a talented
politician and that one is just a big
swing and a miss there
wanted to also ask you about the fact
that these governors are moving much
faster than president biden i think the
polling data must have been quite
something to make them want to get ahead
of him on this but again i just want to
get your take on the politics of it as
president biden watches a lot of his
friends and supporters decide to move on
without him
well i mean i think that he is going to
use the state of the union address in a
few weeks to basically declare that he
has ended covet you saw a preview of
that yesterday when representative
hakeem jeffries actually came out and
said that the reason that kovid is now
on the downswing is because of joe
biden's policies of course he can't
explain why that would be because it's
absolutely untrue and you're seeing the
same thing from wide swaths of the left
which have declared that the only reason
they're loosening up now is because
they're following the science let's be
clear the data have not changed one iota
with regard to kovid since the onset of
omicron and truly with regard to the
vaccines since the vaccines were widely
available this is not about the data it
is about the politics the american
people said enough and they should
remember that these politicians punished
them for two years with bad policy
because they lied to them and said they
could control the virus when they could
not and then they suggested that they
had a level of control over the virus
even beyond the vaccines that exceeds
the capacity of human beings period
and they said they were surprised by it
by omicron and we can handle a lot too
ben thank you nice to see you eventually
come back okay
and we'll have more time and excited
about your movie that's coming out shut
in this
weekend uh free on youtube i know that
you have a brand new venture and
congratulations on that we look forward
to it thank you ben hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now